مع ان سيناء التي تمتد التي تمتد من
الحدود بين مصر واسرائيل الى حوالي 200
كيلومتر عام 79 الملحق الامني لاتفاقيه
كام ديفيد بين اسرائيل ومصر انذاك قسم
سيناء الى ثلاثه اقسام رئيسيه اي وبي وسي
كما نشاهد على الخريطه ايه هي المنطقه
الابعد عن الحدود به هي المنطقه الوسطى
والسي هي المنطقه الاقرب لماذا هذا
التقسيم الذي
فعل بعد الاتفاقيه مباشره بعد الانسحاب
الاسرائيلي من سيناء وهو بالمناسبه نفس
الاتفاق او التقسيم الذي حدث بعد اتفاقيه
اوسلو في الضفه الغربيه وقطاع غزه تقسيم
الاراضي الى الف وباء وجيم
هو تقسيم امني في اي وبي وسي لا يسمح
للجنود المصريين
بالاقتراب من المنطقه من دخول المناطق ب
وجيم او بي وسيم الجيش المصري فقط موجود
في المنطقه a ومحدود الوجود في هذه
المنطقه حوالي 22 الف جندي فقط مسموح لهم
بالتواجد في المنطقه
وهي المنطقه الاقرب الى الى الى قناه
السويس كما نشاهد على الخريطه يمنع
التواجد العسكري المصري في مناطق بي وسي
وهي المناطق الاكثر مساحه او اكثر مساحه
بالنسبه لسيناء كما نشاهد على الخريطه
وبالتالي الوجود الامني المصري في هذه
النقاط هو وجود شرطي بدرجه اساسيه الا اذا
كان هناك تنسيق بين الطرفين يسمح للجيش
المصري بالدخول وهذا ما حدث فعلا عام
2021 بعد ان زادت التحديات الامنيه
بالنسبه لمصر في هذا الشريط الحدودي مع
التكاثف او مع وجود تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه في هذه المنطقه وبالتالي تم
التنسيق بين ودخل الجيش المصري للتنفيذ
عمليات هجوميه لهذه المنطقه الحدوديه هذه
المنطقه الحدوديه كما تابعنا هي التي تمتد
الى حوالي 200 كيلو متر من طابا جنوبا الى
رفح في الشمال الغربي 200 كيلو متر
والعمليه التي وقعت اليوم وقعت في الجزء
الشمالي الغربي من الحدود منطقه معبر
العوجه بصوره اقرب الى هذه الخريطه نتحدث
عن حوالي 40 كيلومتر عن رفح عن الحدود مع
قطاع غزه مع رفح او رفح النصريه رفح
ونتحدث عن هذا المعبر المهم حوالي كما
ذكرنا 40 كيلومتر عن عن عن رفح الحديث
الان الحديث الان بانه عند الساعه الرابعه
ونصف فجرا نفذت هذه العمليه في هذه النقطه
ولم يكتشف جنود الجيش الاسرائيلي العمليه
الا بعد ساعات طويله هذا المعبر المهم
الذي نتحدث عنه في هذه
نتحدث عن هذا المعبر الواقع في قريه
العوجه هذه النقطه الاسرائيليه من المعبر
معبر العوجه وهذه النقطه المصريه من معبر
العوجه كما نشاهد على الخريطه هذا المعبر
مخصص لحركه للحركه التجاريه والحركه
الدبلوماسيه منه تدخل البضائع من الاراضي
48 الى مصر وبالعكس من مصر الى اراضي ال
48 وبالتالي هذا المعبر معبر يعتبر احد
اهم المعابر بين الطرفين لانه يقع في نقطه
بالغه الاهميه والحساسيه بالنسبه لاسرائيل
على وجه التحديد بالنسبه لمصر قد تبدو هذه
المنطقه منطقه رخوه امنيا كما ذكرنا لعدم
وجود عناصر من الجيش المصري في هذه
المنطقه ووجود شرطي مدني فقط في هذه
المنطقه منطقه سي على الحدود او سي من من
من سيناء اذا ما تحدثنا عن المنطقه
بالجانب الاسرائيلي فنحن نتحدث عن هذه
المنطقه ماذا يعرف بمنطقه النقب والتي تضم
عده مدن القرى في داخل الحدود داخل مناطق
ال 48 وهذا هو معبر العوجه الذي نشاهده
على الخريطه وبالتالي نتحدث عن هذه
المنطقه صحيح ان المنطقه عدد السكان فيها
قليل ليست منطقه استراتيجيه من ناحيه
الامنيه او من ناحيه السكانيه بالنسبه
لاسرائيل ولكنها بطبيعه الحال نتحدث عن
منطقه رخوه امنيه وصعبه للغايه لعده اسباب
اولا طول الحدود بين الجانبين فنحن نتحدث
عن 200 كيلومتر بين مصر واسرائيل من طابا
الى رفح كما شاهدنا نتحدث عن مناطق
الجغرافيه صعبه تضاريس صعبه للغايه نتحدث
عن صحراء سيناء المنطقه تقريبا هذه
المناطق شبه الخاليه من السكان
وبالتالي نتحدث عن مناطق صعبه الان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقول بان عمليات التمشيط ما
زالت مستمره في هذه المنطقه لاننا نتحدث
عن دائره تقريبا اذا ما قدرنا وفق
البيانات اوليه فنحن نتحدث عن هذه الدائره
التي مركزها معبر العوجه وبالتالي نتحدث
عن دائره نصف قطرها من عشره الى 15
كيلومترا على الحدود بين الجانبين اذا ما
افترضنا بان منفذ العمليه دخل من هذه
المنطقه فقد يكون الان في هذه المنطقه من
الجانب المصري اذا افترضنا بان منفذ
العمليه او المنفذين او القوات
الاسرائيليه تقول حتى الان انه منفذ من
الشرطه المصريه ولكن حتى الان لا يمكن
الجزم بانه منفذ واحد قد يكون معه اناس
اخرون عاونوه في هذه العمليه قد يكون في
هذه المنطقه وقد يكون في داخل اراضي 48 في
داخل هذه المنطقه الاسرائيليه وبالتالي
عمليات التمشيط كما تقول القوات
الاسرائيليه ما زالت مستمره بالتعاون مع
الجيش المصري